THE TIME FOR ACCOUNTABILITY IS
UPON US.
JOINING ME NOW FOR REACTION,
SENATOR FOR THE GREAT STATE OF
SOUTH CAROLINA, CHAIRMAN OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, WELCOME TO
YOU SENATOR , LINDSEY GRAHAM.
>> YOU’RE DOING REALLY GOOD,
IT’S A GOOD DAY FOR THE RULE OF
LAW.
>> Trey: I WAS THINKING ON THE
WAY OVER HERE, OVER THE PAST
FOUR YEARS THERE HAVE BEEN MORE
FBI EMPLOYEES INDICTED THEM
THERE HAVE BEEN TRUMP FAMILY
MEMBERS, WHAT DOES THAT SAY
ABOUT WHAT THE COUNTRY HAS BEEN
THROUGH OVER THE LAST FOUR
YEARS?
>> THERE ARE A COUPLE
STORY LINES TODAY.
AND FBI LAWYER IN CHARGE OF
REVIEWING WARRANTS IS GOING TO
PLEAD GUILTY TO FALSIFIED
DOCUMENTS TO THE FISA COURT
AGAINST A TRUMP ADVISOR, AND IF
YOU ARE LUCKY, YOU’LL FIND THIS
IN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA FOR 30
SECONDS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF THE SHOE WERE
ON THE OTHER FOOT AND THE FBI
LAWYER PLED GUILTY TODAY TO
FALSIFIED DOCUMENTS AGAINST
HILLARY CLINTON ADVISORS, IT
WOULD BE FRONT PAGE NEWS.
THAT’S THE WORLD WE LIVE IN.
I WANT TO APPLAUD MR. HOROWITZ,
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL -- WITHOUT
HIM, WE WOULDN’T HAVE KNOWN
THIS.
WHAT THIS LAWYER DID IS A REALLY
BIG DEAL.
WE HAVE TO TRUST THE SYSTEM,
THERE HAS TO BE A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF TRUST.
THIS IS A LAWYER, A MAN OF THE
LAW, A MEMBER OF THE BAR WHO
TOOK IT UPON HIMSELF TO
FALSIFIED DOCUMENTS AND KEEP AN
INVESTIGATION GOING THAT
SHOULD’VE BEEN STOPPED.
THE MEDIA CAN’T FIGURE OUT WHY,
THIS IS A BIG DAY FOR THE RULE
OF LAW.
SOMETHING TELLS ME THAT
MR. CLINESMITH KNOWS WHERE THE
BODIES ARE BURIED, AND IF I WERE
IN THE FBI WORKING ON CROSSFIRE
HURRICANE, I WOULD BE VERY
WORRIED RIGHT NOW.
>> Trey: SPEAKING OF WORKING
FOR THE FBI AND BEING WORRIED,
YOU WERE CONCERNED THE FBI MAYBE
HAD MISLED THE SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE, CAN YOU
UPDATE US ON THAT?
>> THIS IS A BIG DAY FOR
TRANSPARENCY AND THE RULE OF LAW
LAW.
MR. HORWITZ -- IT’S NOT IN HIS
REPORT, BUT HE FOUND A BRIEFING
DOCUMENT DATED SOMETIME IN
FEBRUARY 2018 THAT WAS PREPARED
BY THE FBI BECAUSE THE SENATE
INTEL COMMITTEE USED TO BE ON
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE, HAD
REAL CONCERNS ABOUT THE RUSSIAN
SUB SOURCE.
THEY ASKED OF THE TO COME IN AND
BRIEF HIM.
I ASKED DIRECTOR WRAY WHO DID
THE BRIEFINGS.
IT’S BILL PRIESTAP, HE’S ONE OF
THE LEADERS OF CROSSFIRE
HURRICANE.
HE TOLD THE FBI IN 2017 THERE IS
ZERO CORROBORATION FOR THE
DOSSIER, I WOULDN’T TRUST IT
WITH A SOLID GRAIN OF SALT.
THEY KNEW FOR OVER A YEAR AND
NOW YOU’VE GOT BILL PRIESTAP ON
FEBRUARY 15TH 2018 WITH 4 OTHER
PEOPLE FROM THE FBI BRIEFING
THIS SENATE INTEL COMMITTEE,
COMPLETELY WHITEWASHING THE
TRUTH ABOUT THE RELIABILITY OF
THE DOSSIER.
DIRECTOR RAY HAS BEEN REALLY
GOOD, HE’S GIVEN ME THE
INFORMATION BUT WHAT I WANT TO
DO WITH THIS IS TURN IT OVER TO
DURHAM BECAUSE I THINK THE
BRIEFING IN 2018, A YEAR AFTER
THE SOURCE TOLD THE FBI IT WAS A
BUNCH OF GARBAGE, WHITEWASHING
THAT REPORT IS POTENTIALLY
ANOTHER CRIME.
I’M GOING TO SEND ALL OF THIS TO
DURHAM WHEN I GET IT.
>> Trey: THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE WATCHING DEMOCRATS AND
MAYORS OF LIBERAL AND
PROGRESSIVE CITIES COMPLAIN
ABOUT STATE AND LOCAL POLICE
MISCONDUCT.
WHERE IS THE OUTRAGE AMONG
DEMOCRATS WHEN YOU HAVE POLICE
MISCONDUCT OVER AN ENTITY THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE POWER OVER,
CONTROL OVER WHICH IS THE FBI.
WHY IS THERE NOT MORE BIPARTISAN
OUTRAGE OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS
YEARS?
>> TO MY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
DEMOCRATS.
THIS IS ABOUT THE RULE OF LAW.
MANY OF YOU HAVE BEEN U.S.
ATTORNEYS.
WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS AN FBI
LAWYER FALSIFIED DOCUMENTS TO
THE FISA COURT TO KEEP AN
INVESTIGATION GOING THAT SHOULD
HAVE STOPPED.
FALSIFYING DOCUMENTS TO GET A
WARRANT AGAINST AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN, PART OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
WE NOW HAVE IN 2018, A YEAR
AFTER THEY TOLD THE FBI IT WAS A
BUNCH OF GARBAGE, THE DOSSIER,
AN EFFORT BY THE FBI TO LIE TO
CONGRESS AND THE REASON THAT
PRESTAFF LIED TO CONGRESS IS IF
HE TOLD WHAT THE TRUTH, HE WOULD
EXPOSE THE LIE TO THE COURT.
MR. HOROWITZ DESERVES A LOT OF
CREDIT HERE.
THE NEXT THING I’M GOING TO DO
IS I’M GOING TO CALL TO THE
COMMITTEE AND INTERVIEW THE CASE
AGENT AND THE INTEL ANALYST WHO
INTERVIEWED THE RUSSIAN SUB
SOURCE IN JANUARY AND MARCH OF
2017 AND THEY GOT MEMOS SHOWING
IT WAS A BUNCH OF GARBAGE, THE
GUIDE DENIED THE RELIABILITY OF
THE DOSSIER, ZERO CORROBORATION
AND HERE’S A SIMPLE QUESTION.
THE MOST HIGH-PROFILE CASE MAY
BE EVER IN THE HISTORY OF THE
FBI, COMPLETELY FELL APART IN
TERMS OF RELIABILITY.
WHO DID YOU TELL?
WHAT IS THE LIKELIHOOD THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO INTERVIEWED THE
RUSSIAN SUB SOURCE DID NOT TELL
McCABE, EVENTUALLY CALL ME,
OUR CASE FELL APART?
THAT’S WHERE I’M HEADED.
IF THEY KNEW ABOUT THIS
INTERVIEW, IF THEY GOT A WARRANT
IN APRIL OR JUNE MONTHS AFTER
THE INTERVIEW, THEY SHOULD GO TO
JAIL.
>> Trey: LET ME ASK YOU
QUICKLY, WE GOT ABOUT 20
SECONDS, WHAT IS THE FUTURE IF
ANY OF THE FISA COURT?
>> IT’S HANGING IN THE BALANCE
BECAUSE PEOPLE ABUSE POWER AND
GOD KNOWS WE NEED IT BECAUSE THE
TERRORISTS ARE COMING AFTER US,
WE HAVE TO REHABILITATE THE
SYSTEM.
THE ONLY WAY PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
TRUST THE FBI AND PFIZER IN THE